[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 8 juin voici le programme de ce
soir samedi prochain c'est la fête des
enfants à Voisins-le-Bretonneux cette
année le thème me porte sur les héros au
programme des rencontres avec les
célèbres Pikachu Mario ou encore
pat'patrouille on fait le point avec la
mère de la ville Alexandra Rosetti un
véritable voyage dans le temps en 1883
exactement le week-end dernier un train
d'avant-guerre a effectuer Versailles
chantier Massy-Palaiseau l'idée célébrer
les 140 ans de la ligne de chemin de fer
devenu le RER C à son bord des passagers
des musiciens des serveurs le tout en
tenue d'époque et à partir de demain
jusqu'au 18 juin ce sont les nuits des
forêts partout en France plusieurs
rendez-vous sont prévus dans les
Yvelines notamment dans la forêt de
Rambouillet c'est l'occasion de se
rendre compte de l'importance de la
forêt et de rencontrer ceux qui
l'entretiennent et la protège on en
parle avec nos invités et ce sera dans
notre partie loisir avec comme chaque
jeudi notre journaliste Gabriel Gontier
qui nous partagera ses idées de sortie
dans les Yvelines pour le week-end dans
cette émission également notre chronique
sur le bien-être animal avec atisse
barré mais avant de dérouler ce beau
programme petit tour de plateau
Alexandra Rosetti bonsoir bonsoir alors
je le disais à l'instant vous êtes la
mère de Voisins le bretonneux et du coup
samedi vous organisez la fête des
enfants dans votre commune à quoi
faut-il s'attendre c'est quoi la fête
des enfants à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
alors c'est une fête comme son nom
l'indique pour les enfants donc il va y
avoir des enfants partout dans l'espace
culturel de Cauville avec beaucoup de
surprises évidemment et c'est vraiment
un moment très très festif avec des
enfants de tout petit de l'âge de de la
crèche on va dire jusqu'aux enfants qui
qui sont en CM2 et donc on parlera du
programme en détail dans quelques
instants avec nous également un plateau
Clara enguenau bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
la cofondatrice des nuits des forêts et
Brigitte teinturier bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes la responsable marketing et
commercial de l'Espace Rambouillet en
quelques mots c'est quoi aujourd'hui
l'importance de cette de ces nuits des
forêts pourquoi c'est important de
continuer à fêter cet événement
aujourd'hui
alors les forêts sont des lieux
absolument essentiels pour les citoyens
c'est aussi des lieux qui occupent
beaucoup d'espace en Île-de-France c'est
un quart de la région dans les Yvelines
c'est même plus je crois près d'un tiers
mais ce sont des
ce sont des lieux qu'on me connaît mal
on sait pas toujours comment elles sont
entretenues comme qu'est-ce qu'il faut
faire et pas faire en forêt et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on organise cet
événement tous les ans pour laisser
célébrer mais aussi pour mieux vivre
avec elle et c'est pour ça que l'Espace
Rambouillet fait partie de cet événement
aussi l'Espace Rambouillet c'est avant
tout une forêt justement qui est un bel
outil pédagogique que l'on utilise au
quotidien pour à culturer les gens les
informer les sensibiliser à la
biodiversité et c'est vrai que ça a
forcément du sens d'être présent pour
les nuits des forêts pour pour aller
auprès du plus grand nombre puisque
c'est un événement qui est gratuit en
plus donc on en parlera en détail tout à
l'heure avec nous également une
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
réginera les bonsoir bonsoir avec vous
on verra dans quelques instants les
informations à retenir dans les Yvelines
mais avant je vous propose de jeter un
coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil sera toujours
parmi nous dans les Yvelines mais le
ciel sera légèrement voilé à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Rambouillet
au niveau des températures il fera 22 à
21 degrés en moyenne dans l'après-midi
même programme du soleil avec un ciel
légèrement voilé côté température il
fera 29 degrés à Houdan Versailles et
Rambouillet et 30 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et demain nous fêterons
les Diane le point maintenant sur les
informations du jour à retenir dans les
Yvelines
[Musique]
et on commence avec cette information
Régine a tous eu le noble les avions
vont voler sans mettre plus haut pour
réduire les nuisances aériennes et oui
une expérimentation va peut-être faire
évoluer le conflit entre les habitants
et les utilisateurs de l'aérodrome de
toussu le noble on vous en parler
d'ailleurs en mai dernier lors d'une
mobilisation des habitants qui demandent
depuis plusieurs années la réduction du
trafic aérien et la mise en place
d'indicateurs pour mesurer la baisse des
niveaux sonores en réponse la mère de la
commune Vanessa au roi a annoncé que la
trajectoire des avions allait être
réhaussée de 100 mètres durant des tests
au mois de septembre alors l'impact
sonore sera mesuré et s'il était se sont
concluants ces modifications de
trajectoire pourrait être appliquées
durablement Valérie Pécresse demande un
retour à la normale suite au
dysfonctionnements des bus à Poissy et
oui d'ailleurs souvenez-vous également
le 9 mai dernier une réorganisation des
lignes de bus avait été opéré par
Île-de-France mobilité le but c'était de
rendre plus accessible et plus
compréhensible le réseau de bus de
Poissy Les Mureaux mais après quelques
semaines d'expérimentation les usagers
ne semblent pas satisfaits du service
Valérie Pécresse la Présidente de la
Région Île-de-France souhaite à leur
mettre en place une campagne de
communication à l'écoute des usagers de
tous les bus pour identifier les
dysfonctionnements
1,6 millions d'euros Régine c'est le
chiffre du jour pourquoi alors 1,6
millions d'euros c'est ce qu'a coûté le
dispositif mobility c'est un dispositif
du département pour développer
l'électromobilité en zone rurale dans
les Yvelines et ce par la mise en place
d'ombrière photovoltaïques de véhicules
électriques et de bornes de recharge
Condé sur vertge et la première commune
à prendre part à l'expérimentation est
ici la fin 2025 le département espère
généraliser le dispositif au 154
villages Yvelines noires restants et le
campus départemental de formation Paul
Cézanne organise sa première journée
portes ouverte ce sera à Mantes-la-Jolie
tout à fait Mathilde et ça se passe
d'ailleurs le 10 juin de 10h à 17h le
campus ouvrira ses portes au collégien
et lycéen des Yvelines qui sont dans des
situations précaires que ce soit des
décrocheurs des bénéficiaires du RSA et
ou dès demandeurs d'emploi pendant cette
journée plusieurs formations
qualifiantes certifiantes et ou
diplômante seront présentées dans les
secteurs des travaux publics de la
coiffure ou encore du numérique et ces
dernières pourront être intégrés dès la
rentrée 2023 2024 et on termine avec un
mot de sport Régine aujourd'hui se
terminer le championnat de France UNSS
de golf des collégiens exactement et le
championnat a débuté lundi au golf des
boucles de la Seine à Moisson les 35
équipes de 28 collèges ont joué mardi et
mercredi et ont disputait les finales
aujourd'hui les équipes étaient
réparties en trois catégories excellence
pour les joueurs avec un classement
élevé de sections sportives
établissement pour les joueurs
d'associations sportives traditionnelles
et enfin des équipes partagées avec des
joueurs valides et des joueurs en
situation de handicap les petits joueurs
et arbitres coacher durant l'année par
leur professeur d'EPS ont pu défendre
les couleurs de leur collège écoutez ces
réactions au micro de Nicolas dandry
final je veux jouer le rôle d'arbitre ça
consiste c'est assez simple ça consiste
juste en compter déjà le score
en
faire taire les autres pendant que
quelqu'un joue pour qu'il puisse se
concentrer et je puis je dois aussi un
peu accélérer le rythme de la partie
c'est un peu une finalité UNSS et ces
deux choses c'est à la fois la
découverte un peu de d'une activité et
puis il y a une finalité un peu plus
compétitive et là c'est championnat de
France bah c'est le c'est l'apogée de
cette compétition donc et puis
excellence donc c'est le meilleur niveau
et être qualifié en finale c'est quelque
chose très très sympa c'est une belle
expérience c'est important c'est une
vitrine on essaye de montrer au golf à
la Fédération de golf qui travaillait
avec nous mais aussi à tous les élèves
que on peut leur organiser une
compétition professionnelle parce que
c'est vraiment avec des conditions comme
ils peuvent rencontrer dans des d'autres
compétitions fédérales mais vraiment
adapté au scolaire le format les
règlements pour que tout le monde joue
et tout le monde y trouve son compte
et justement on a entendu Olivier coffre
du lycée international de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye bien c'est son
équipe qui a remporté la coupe dans la
catégorie Excellence bravo à nos petits
collégiens yvelinois bravo à eux et
merci beaucoup Régine radèche pour
toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
information ou une image qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
cette semaine vous l'avez compris c'est
la Semaine de la santé sexuelle à cette
occasion le département des Yvelines
organisé vendredi dernier une table
ronde pour présenter les actions des
centres de santé sexuelle Karine araza
influenceuse et ambassadrice de la team
78 nous explique les enjeux au micro de
Gabriel Gontier
[Musique]
avec le département qui avait justement
envie de communiquer autour des centres
de santé sexuelle pour montrer
l'importance qu'ils avaient sur le
territoire et donc nous pour faire
connaître ces centres de santé sexuelles
on a eu l'idée de d'organiser une table
ronde avec Sandrine Arcizet qui est
aussi chroniqueuse et marraine de la
team 78 Edwige justement qu'un compte
Instagram avec plus de 200 000 abonnés
et deux références santé et ça
permettait en fait d'aller chercher une
audience assez large puisqu'elles ont
des communautés très grandes et
d'informer le plus grand nombre sur ce
que fait le département pour les centres
de santé sexuelle et ce que fait les
centres surtout pour les Yvelines
[Musique]
ça va être d'informer aussi d'éduquer
sur la vie affective la vie sexuelle on
va retrouver des sages-femmes des
médecins pour pouvoir aussi avoir des
consultations qui sont totalement prises
en charge et ça permet aux jeunes
d'avoir des personnes à qui parler à qui
communiquer parce que des fois c'est
peut-être pas forcément au sein de sa
famille on a peut-être pas les bons
interlocuteurs donc ça permet aussi de
décloisonner un peu les discours autour
de la sexualité et d'être un peu dans
une safe place où on se sent en sécurité
et à l'écoute
[Musique]
ça permet de les casser surtout ça
permet de je pense décomplexer aussi au
sujet de la sexualité parce que c'est
pas forcément quelque chose dont on
parle mais en revanche voilà d'avoir des
référentes qui en parlent d'avoir des
influenceurs aussi qui prennent la
parole sur ces sujets c'est important ce
que ça permet de se dire en fait moi qui
pensais que c'était un tabou finalement
ça en est pas on se pose tous les mêmes
questions et au final ça permet aussi je
pense de de casser les codes et d'ouvrir
aussi les questions sur ce sujet là
[Musique]
on en parlait en début d'émission samedi
prochain c'est la fête des enfants à
Voisins le bretonneux pour en parler
avec nous Alexandra Rosetti la mère de
la commune pourquoi c'est important pour
vous d'organiser cette fête des enfants
dans votre commune alors c'est une fête
qui vient mettre un peu qui vient
célébrer la fin de l'année scolaire et
bon on a toujours fait des fêtes pour
les enfants et en particulier plutôt
avec les centres de loisirs et là l'idée
c'est vraiment de que tout le monde
toutes les professionnels qui s'occupent
des enfants sur la commune travaille
ensemble pour produire cette fête donc
ça va de nos assistantes maternelles de
nos Atsems dans les écoles les
puéricultrices dans les crèches jusque à
nos centres de loisirs avec les
enseignants qui le souhaitent l'idée de
produire vraiment une journée très
festive autour de ce qu'ils ont pu faire
dans l'année et puis voilà une fesse une
façon de fêter l'arrivée de l'été dans
la bonne humeur et alors quelles seront
les activités que vous allez proposer
alors le thématique c'est les héros les
super-héros du héros du quotidien
d'ailleurs voilà alors il y a il va y
avoir des fabrications de masques des
couronnes de héros des un bouclier
super-héros je vous fais la liste j'en
ai plein la question de customisation de
héros et super-héros la pêche elle ligne
de la course en sac enfin voilà donc ça
va être une journée avec plein de jeux
il y a également des spectacles des
spectacles pour les petits jusqu'à 5 ans
les spectacles aussi des écoliers qui
ont pu préparer des choses avec leur
instituteurs ce sont des spectacles
qu'ils ont préparé tout au long de
l'année là c'est une restitution voilà
tout à fait et puis on a Emma la
guerrière qui va déambuler avec son
cheval Fuego quand même
il y aura un cheval présent samedi
et puis surtout nous avons aussi une
Rosalie maintenant nous avons acheté un
vélo électrique de 9 places donc voilà
l'occasion aussi de se promener un petit
peu
donc je pense que ça va être des moments
assez assez intéressants les enfants
adorent ça se prendre en photo avec eux
et tous les ans on cherche une
thématique différente l'année dernière
c'était sur le voyage donc il y avait
tout le monde était déguisé en studio
enfin bon donc c'est vraiment moi en
tant que mais en tout cas ce que
j'apprécie aussi c'est que les équipes
comme je l'ai dit descente de loisirs
aussi
travaillent ensemble ça crée de
l'émulation et
avec nos écoles aussi donc ça a beaucoup
de vertus et je crois qu'il faut pas
oublier son costume de super-héros
également mais non moi je vous dis pas
comment je serai déguisée évidemment
mais bien sûr évidemment
est-ce que ça vous donne envie d'y aller
bon vous êtes un peu plus vieille un peu
plus vieille que 9 ans
que ce que vous pensez de cette
initiative Clara engono et Brigitte
teinturier moi je trouve ça formidable
de toute manière dès qu'on dès qu'on met
des enfants dans des contextes avec des
thématiques amusantes c'est clair que
voir les enfants sourire c'est ce qu'il
y a de plus sympathique c'est un
rayonnement pour tout le monde donc
ça me donne envie de venir j'ai un petit
bout de chou on croit juste les doigts
pour la météo bien entendu mais on fait
la danse du soleil depuis deux jours là
donc ça devrait le faire
de la pluie un peu un peu dans la vue
oui mais là mais t'es où se trouve tout
le temps c'est bien justement vous
attendez combien de personnes est-ce que
c'est devenu un rendez-vous c'est
vraiment devenu un rendez-vous d'autant
plus que comme les temps sont un peu
durs c'est vrai qu'on a on a réduit un
petit peu la voilure sur certains
événements mais celui-là on a vraiment
voulu le garder intact et on peut avoir
entre 500 et 800 personnes sans problème
et bien merci beaucoup Alexandra merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation pour
rappel du coup la fête des enfants c'est
samedi prochain le 10 juin à partir de
14h et c'est à l'espace culturel de
Cauville et au jardin Eugène fleuret de
Voisins le bretonneux et après avoir
parlé super héros Pikachu
matériaux je vous propose un voyage dans
le temps de 140 ans dimanche dernier un
train d'avant-guerre c'était lancé de la
guerre de Versailles-Chantiers jusqu'à
Massy-Palaiseau au total ce sont plus de
200 participants qui ont embarqué en
1883 pour commémorer les 140 ans de la
ligne du RER C Régine relève nous fait
découvrir les coulisses
[Musique]
1er mai 1883 le tronçon de train entre
Versailles-Chantiers et Massy est
inauguré pour la première fois
140 ans plus tard l'inauguration est
célébrée par le passage d'un train
d'avant-guerre sur la ligne de la Grande
Ceinture de Paris avec des arrêts au
garde petitjouis les loges de la Bièvre
Dini et de Massy
aujourd'hui c'est un affrontement
l'association que je préside est affrêté
par un comité d'élus de la vallée de la
Bièvre pour effectivement commémorer les
140 ans de la Ligue de RER C ligne sur
laquelle le circule aujourd'hui pour
nous c'est important ces anniversaires
là c'est comme hémoration et en plus la
note notre client à freteur vient avec
ses administrés costumés costumes
d'époque avec nos voitures c'est c'est
le mélange rêvé en fait le train a
accueilli plus de 250 personnes à son
bord pour un voyage d'une heure 40 au
programme exposition photo retraçant les
140 ans d'exploitation de la ligne
musique d'antan en live et collation au
bar je vous avoue que je suis ému je
suis ému en plus vraiment les il y a
beaucoup de gens il y a beaucoup de
personnes qui ont joué le jeu de des
costumes donc c'est vraiment on enfin
moi je suis revenu en 1930 quoi enfin
avant guerre et c'est très émouvant
alors on a choisi une tenue
raccord avec les peuples donc là on est
plutôt
191880 j'adore là en fait c'est génial
c'est magnifique
cet événement c'était l'occasion de
commémorer les 140 ans de la ligne mais
aussi de marquer le lancement d'un tout
nouveau projet la mise en circulation
d'une navette entre Versailles et Massy
la ligne C du RER sera déconnectée et
nous aurons une petite navette qui sera
plus régulière qui permettra aussi au
vélo d'entrer dans le train et nous
espérons que ce sera un outil de
développement touristique pour notre
territoire un projet qui verra le jour
en décembre 2023 suite à la mise en
service du tram 30 12
allez c'est l'heure à présent de passer
à notre page loisirs
[Musique]
et on commence cette page loisir avec
les nuits des forêts à partir de demain
et jusqu'au 18 juin l'événement se
déroule partout en France dans les
Yvelines plusieurs activités sont
proposées pour en parler avec nous Clara
anguenau la cofondatrice des nuits des
forêts et Brigitte teinturier la
responsable commerciale et marketing de
l'Espace Rambouillet Clara enguenau
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé
d'où est venu cette idée de créer les
nuits des forêts donc vu cette idée
alors c'est un festival qu'on a imaginé
en fait pendant le premier confinement
donc on va dire que au début elle est
venue surtout d'un besoin de prendre
l'air et de d'aller en pleine nature
et aussi on avait à coeur de de créer un
temps pour aller à la rencontre de de
personnes qui connaissent bien les
forêts soit parce qu'il étudient des
scientifiques des chercheurs ou parce
qu'ils l'entretiennent comme des
gestionnaires forestiers par exemple ou
des propriétaires
et le tout on voulait le faire quand
même dans un esprit festif pour en faire
quand même un temps convivial et comme
je disais on était en plein confinement
donc il y avait une volonté aussi de
partager des moments forts et c'est
comme ça qu'on a eu l'idée d'un festival
et qui a du coup aussi toute une
dimension artistique et ludique et pas
seulement pédagogique alors pourquoi le
faire la nuit alors c'est je précise que
c'est le jour et la nuit mais c'est vrai
que la spécificité du festival et que on
a beaucoup d'événements qui durent
pendant la nuit
l'idée c'était
d'inviter à aller découvrir la forêt de
manière originale on a l'habitude
d'aller en forêt pour les champignons le
VTT quelques pique-nique escalade mais
là on voulait aussi inviter à sortir un
peu de sa zone de confort et puis aussi
à la nuit qui tombe on a toute la faune
qui se réveille donc pour observation
écoute des oiseaux
d'autres animaux c'est très propice
voilà et puis après c'était la nuit
aussi l'univers
fantastique voilà onirique derrière la
forêt qu'on voulait mettre à l'honneur à
travers ce titre et alors l'Espace
Rambouillet participe à cet événement
Brigitte teinturier quelles sont les
activités que vous allez proposer cette
année alors nous on a une soirée qui se
déroule en plusieurs temps
justement parce que on va commencer
entre chiens et loups au moment où il
fait encore jour mais
justement les nocturnes ne sont pas
encore sorties donc on va démarrer par
une petite balade forestière pour venir
découvrir la forêt et ses secrets
on va en livrer quelques-uns en tout cas
on espère surprendre un petit peu nos
invités
on a nous au niveau du parc un espace
qu'on appelle la forêt sauvage qui se
prête particulièrement bien puisque
dessus on a des animaux qui sont en
semi-liberté et donc on va
faire une petite balade au sein de ces
parcelles là arriver à la mars
Saint-Rémy qui est un lieu vraiment très
atypique du parc pour ensuite profiter
en fait d'un vol de nos rapaces puisque
l'espace a aussi la forêt des aigles une
volière avec des rapaces que l'on
présente en vol et qui seront
accompagnés justement sur cette partie
artistique d'une joueuse de harpe
donc ça c'est quelque chose qui va nous
on a vraiment conçu une approche très
grand public et cette soirée ensuite
nous ramène à nouveau au niveau de de la
forêt et là on va avoir un spectacle
vivant ou en fait on va aborder en fait
le sujet des arthropodes qui sont les
petits insectes les pollinisateurs qui
sont essentiels à l'écosystème de la
forêt donc
le concept a été travaillé sur une base
pour être accessible à notre public qui
est un public familial
et qui en même temps un moyen d'offrir
une découverte justement originale et
unique de ce lieu qui est l'Espace
Rambouillet oui si je comprends bien
l'objectif c'est de faire connaître la
faune et la flore dans les forêts qui
sont proches de chez nous finalement oui
et d'évoquer en fait ce qu'est la forêt
en soi
par rapport à ces enjeux historiques et
c'est là où on rejoint vraiment le
souhait des nuits des forêts de d'offrir
justement une information variée et
divers sur les écosystèmes que rendent
la forêt aujourd'hui donc on a un
partenaire qui est FIBOIS qui sera
présent aussi sur sur l'espace et dont
la vocation justement est de promouvoir
tous les métiers autour du bois et alors
plus largement Clara engono quel est le
programme dans les Yvelines de ces nuits
des forêts
alors donc les événements sont
essentiellement sur les deux weekends à
venir dans les Yvelines et donc ce
week-end c'est beaucoup sur le massif de
Rambouillet il y a l'ONF l'Office
National des Forêts organise une sortie
nocturne un spectacle de contes par une
compagnie qui s'appelle la Cour des
comptes mais compte histoire pas les
contraintes il y a aussi un très beau
concert de violoncelle en forêt de Santa
Pauline
c'est une violence qui s'appelle Olivia
gay qui a un qui porte un projet mais à
titre citoyen pour faire découvrir le
répertoire de musique classique et ses
liens avec la nature et donc voilà pour
pour promouvoir aussi la beauté des
forêts et comme source d'inspiration
donc ça c'est le premier week-end et le
second il y aura encore beaucoup de
choses côté Saint-Germain-en-Laye aussi
il y aura des événements forêt des
portables départementales de ronqueux
une belle sortie par le organisé par le
département des Yvelines pour découvrir
justement les chauves-souris qui sont
des habitants en nocturne et de la forêt
voilà
on découvre donc la faune et la flore
mais aussi il y a des rendez-vous avec
des artistes des rendez-vous artistiques
en plein milieu de la forêt c'est ça
exactement qu'on essaye de faire
toujours la manière la plus légère
possible l'idée on est quand même
toujours sur des petites jauges sur des
interventions très légères des artistes
pour évidemment aussi respecter le
milieu pour être en cohérence aussi avec
les nouvelles et alors comment faire
pour attirer les plusieurs bains ceux
qui sont peut-être moins attirés par la
forêt pour voilà les faire venir assez
nuit des forêts c'est pas facile alors
s'il fait bien chaud ils peuvent avoir
envie de venir se rafraîchir non c'est
vrai que c'est une question il y avait
quand même la problématique des
transports en Île-de-France en tout cas
on sait alors il y a des espaces
naturels notre forestiers est connecté
mais c'est pas toujours bien donc nous
on essaye d'encourager aussi la
communication sur vous pouvez venir
aussi avec une ligne de RER de TER de
Transilien
et puis ensuite je pense que les formats
atypiques
proposés comme comme ce soit l'Espace
Rambouillet et d'autres aident aussi à
attirer une population plus urbaine et
d'avoir ce mélange des genres
différents publics aussi alors le mot de
la fin Brigitte teinturier pourquoi la
forêt c'est important pour vous parce
qu'il est essentielle à notre vie on va
reparler ce sont les poumons de la terre
clairement et puis aujourd'hui bien si
on veut sortir des énergies carbone bien
évidemment ça passe aussi par le
maintien de cette forêt et sa gestion au
quotidien qui est vraiment essentielle
et c'est là où l'ONF entre autres et
aussi les propriétaires privés sont
essentiels pour une gestion raisonnée de
la forêt qui intervient pour aujourd'hui
de nombreux systèmes écosystèmes
des services pour pour la population
dans sa globalité et pour vous Clara
Haguenau pourquoi c'est important la
forêt en quelques mots
ce sont des lieux essentiels à notre
bien-être et presque à notre survie j'ai
envie de dire donc c'est vraiment des
lieux qu'il faut bien connaître qu'il
faut apprendre à protéger mais il faut
aussi apprendre à bien vivre avec elle
et de leur ressources donc c'est
important de d'y aller et bien merci à
vous deux Clara anconnu et Brigitte
teinturier d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors dans les Yvelines les
forêts couvrent plus de 68000 hectares
soit environ 30% de la surface du
département c'est l'un des départements
les plus boisés d'Île-de-France
d'ailleurs donc il y a plusieurs
rendez-vous vous les voyez s'afficher
sur votre écran vous retrouverez tout le
programme sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
et on poursuit cette page loisir avec le
festival des ménographies alors est-ce
que vous savez ce que c'est
et bien il s'agit d'un festival de
photos en plein air international et
gratuit et pour cette troisième édition
ça se déroule dans le petit village des
Mesnuls le reportage de Céline charge la
ville des ménules a habillé son parc et
les gamins pour ce mois de juin cette
commune rurale des Yvelines accueille
cette année 21 photographes de 13 pays
différents à l'occasion du festival Les
ménographies né à la suite des
différents confinements il a pour
objectif de rendre accessible et
démocratisé le médium de la photographie
toutes les photos on a de la photo
partout sur tous nos téléphones toutes
nos applications toutes les publicités
qu'on voit qu'on croise son photo mais
du coup on l'imagine pas comme un media
marktistique et c'est un peu injuste
parce que c'est non seulement un médium
artistique mais aussi à travers ce
médium artistique informatif et il doit
être accessible à tous c'est vraiment
l'idée que n'importe quelle personne
n'importe quel niveau social avec
n'importe quelle éducation puisse passer
la porte du parc et passer un bon moment
et découvrir des choses qui vont lui
plaire c'est toujours pas de problème de
l'art visuel c'est de faire venir le
public parce que tout le monde va pas au
musée ou au moins ici ça permet à une
connexion peut-être avec le public et
puis à l'extérieur c'est toujours
chouette les photographes ont été
choisies par sélection et appels à
candidature cette année le festival
s'articule autour de trois thématiques
phares la maternité l'environnement et
le genre des thèmes actuels abordés à
travers différents regards et qui
traduisent beaucoup d'enjeux sociétaux
contemporains c'est très important pour
moi de montrer la fragilité du monde la
fragilité de la nature le côté éphémère
des fleurs c'est-à-dire que les saisons
le printemps l'été l'automne ou les
fleurs ont une durée de vie beaucoup
plus courte que l'être humain et il faut
en profiter et c'était très important
pour moi de montrer ses fleurs qui ont
vécu qui sont sur le sol que j'ai
ramassées et je leur donne une seconde
existence en le prenant en photo ma mère
la source est un projet qui rend hommage
à mes origines méditerranéennes et aux
femmes de ma famille et c'est un projet
qui parle de la filiation matridinéaire
et de et de transmission au sein d'une
famille par les femmes une série que
j'ai commencé à un an et demi et qui est
né de la volonté de faire le portrait de
d'amis et
personne de mon entourage qui se pose
des questions sur leur genre et sur leur
identité et pas parce que j'en avais
envie d'en faire un sujet mais parce que
mes amis et mes proches sont dans ces
questionnements cette balade artistique
se poursuit dans d'autres communes des
Yvelines des photographies sont exposées
à La Queue-les-Yvelines à la chapelle de
Clairefontaine ou encore à la Maison
Louis Carré de Bazoches-sur-Guyonne
exposition est accessible gratuitement
jusqu'au 25 juin prochain
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par une journaliste de la rédaction
Gabriel Gonthier bonsoir Mathilde comme
d'habitude le jeudi vous nous présenter
vos idées de sortie dans les Yvelines
pour le week-end petit teasing vous
allez nous parler de quoi ce soir on
parlera notamment d'un concert organisé
pour la Journée de l'Europe un concert
par des artistes Ukrainiens donc on en
parlera dans quelques instants ce serait
dans quelques instants avec nous
également ATIS Barret bonsoir bonsoir
Mathilde comme d'habitude vous aussi le
jeudi vous venez pour nous présenter
votre chronique sur le bien-être animal
ce soir vous allez nous parler de chat
je crois oui deux chats de la
vaccination pour les chats qui est très
importante et enfin avec nous François
Jolivet bonsoir alors vous êtes le
président du codative le Comité
Départemental d'animation et de théâtre
amateurs des Yvelines et vous allez
présenter un événement qui se déroulera
du 11 juin jusqu'au 25 juin c'est le
théâtre à la ferme le théâtre dans les
fermes pourquoi ramener le théâtre dans
les fermes tout est dit au niveau de
notre slogan quand les planches
rencontrent les champs je pense que
l'idée c'est de marquer deux choses
différentes qui sont le théâtre et puis
les nourritures terrestres et puis de
faire venir du nouveau public dans des
lieux magnifiques parce qu'on peut à la
fois
c'est pour le plaisir des yeux parce
qu'il y a des très très jolie lieux et
puis
le plaisir aussi des papis puisque on
pourra déguster à sa forme de produits
dans les fermes donc on aura quatre
événements on commence dimanche au
bureau avec la ferme de La Haye il y a
une journée portes ouvertes ensuite le
18 nous serons à la Faisanderie à
Villepreux dans un lieu magnifique on a
si on veut de Bergerac
au bord du Gally ensuite le 21 nous
serons à la ferme de bulloyers
Magny-les-Hameaux à la suite du marché
mercredi après-midi et on terminera par
les Fables de La Fontaine à la ferme des
Mousseaux
Chartres voilà ce qui est important
aussi c'est qu'à chaque fois derrière
c'est ferme il y a des familles des
familles qui sont appuies longtemps et
qui nous ouvre leurs portes et pour nous
c'est formidable parce que ça permet de
à la fois de mettre en valeur le lieu et
puis
et puis de montrer que c'est accessible
à tous le théâtre et qu'on passe un bon
moment voilà et alors pourquoi ces
pièces c'est un eau de Bergerac les
Fables de La Fontaine pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez choisi ces pièces là alors
tout simplement nous ont appelé un
candidature auprès de nos 52 adhérents
52 troupes adhérentes et puis on essaie
de choisir au mieux d'avoir une
cohérence entre le lieu et puis la pièce
que choisit voilà et puis sur certains
lieux on a choisi des pièces plus
courtes
avec l'échange
avec également les les agriculteurs ou
les propriétaires et
pour ce qui est de la ferme notamment
faire de la Faisanderie c'est quand même
propriété de la famille develette madame
Develay a été directrice adjointe
président du handlag c'est-à-dire à
Paris donc on a souhaité trouver en
accord avec la famille une pièce qui me
paraissait à la hauteur à la fois du
lieu et pour lui rendre également
honneur voilà donc pour d'autres on a
d'autres pièces plus courtes on utilise
toute la richesse des troupes
yvelinoises
est devenu cette idée d'amener le
théâtre dans les ferme parce que c'est
quand même quelque chose d'un peu
insolite parce qu'à la fois un peu
insolite alors bon savoir si l'idée
d'avoir deux sujets c'est plus c'est
plus porteur mais semble-t-il ou de
thèmes à titre plus personnel
exclusivement de cette validité ayant
quelques aïeux agriculteurs et Linois je
voilà j'ai proposé cette idée voilà mais
je pense que c'est intéressant d'aller
vers de nouveaux publics en faisant de
nouvelles approches comme vous avez fait
tout à l'heure et c'est très intéressant
de voir cela parce que ça permet d'avoir
une autre approche qui est dans un
moment qui se veut à la fois convivial
et sympathique et on a quatre lieux
extrêmement différents et ça c'est très
très intéressant et des troupes très
motivés qui font qui vont venir jouer
alors l'entrée libre il y aura un
chapeau
nous en mettons donc je dirais
puisque la seconde édition par la
Communauté d'Agglomération de 51 en
Yvelines qui nous a octroyé une petite
latine entière qui est la bienvenue pour
organiser ce type de manifestation voilà
donc on est très heureux de le faire et
très heureux de faire découvrir de
beaulieues dans et puis aussi de bons
produits alimentaires voilà
est-ce que le but c'est pas ça justement
aussi c'est de faire découvrir au
spectateur qu'on peut être plus
l'habitude des salles de théâtre là de
les faire venir dans les fermes
yvelinoises leur faire découvrir un peu
le territoire aussi c'est tout à fait
découvrir le territoire et d'essayer
d'aller on essaie d'être un peu dans des
endroits différents donc on est au
bureau dans un lieu qui est très très
très classique en termes de production
agricole et les lieux un peu plus
prestigieux donc on essaye d'aller un
peu partout
après peut-être que les prochains on ira
dans une autre fait dans plus de ferme
enfin voilà mais si je pense une idée
c'est de à la fois découvrir les lieux
et découvrir la production qu'on y
trouve et de faire profiter je dirais au
public qu'on espère le plus nombreux
possible
par rapport à votre première édition
là ce que vous attendez plus de
personnes on espère avoir plus de plus
de personnes possibles bien évidemment
les gagnants on avait que deux fermes
c'est la première édition là on est
passé à 4 fermes et donc on espère aussi
les fermiers les agriculteurs parce
qu'ils ont souvent des événements et ça
permet de se prendre en jouant contre
leur train c'est une ferme la failli
Fano Martin Fano
le théâtre fin fait sur labyrinthe dans
le maïs pour ce qui est de des Mureaux
la famille frema fait une journée portes
ouvertes dimanche et donc on est on est
dans ce dans ce cadre là pour ce qui est
le plus loyer Bruno et Marc et son
équipe et tous les mercredis avec des
jeunes il y a marché donc on va
se faire connaître aussi on est dans une
démarche comme on dit en management
gagnante mais je pense que c'est
vraiment deux énergies qui se fédères au
service du public des lieux et et je
dirais de la cause agricole voilà
avec la France deux démonstration ont
lieu à partir de 16h30 toute la journée
des animations sont proposées comme de
la musique de la danse autour de
l'Europe début de cet événement Mathilde
14h30 à la salle Jacques Brel la suite à
l'hôtel de ville de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux autre invitation
au voyage Gabriel c'est ce samedi le
festival escale d'ailleurs revient à
Plaisir oui véritable moment d'évasion
pour les familles le festival plaisir
roi revient pour sa 19e édition au
programme musique cirque art de la rue
danse et cuisine du monde le thème cette
année l'Afrique Océanie Philippe Corda
nous en dit plus au micro de Julien
Leroy
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de rassembler un petit peu
tous les acteurs de la ville les
associations petites entreprises autour
du monde de la culture mais également de
faire venir l'intégralité des quartiers
qui se rassemblent ici dans ce lieu
central pour fêter une journée très
familiale très festive et très
sympathique
[Musique]
ça commence l'après-midi par le pôle jeu
qui est essentiellement centré pour les
enfants bien sûr ce sont des jeux en
bois des jeux assez dimensionnants après
on a bien sûr le pôle dense ou là pour
la plupart ce sont les associations qui
ont préparé un spectacle pour se
produire en fin d'année au niveau du
festival et puis on a bien sûr des
démonstrations
circassiennes on aime bien valoriser un
petit peu la rurbain également et on a
de la musique
[Musique]
alors on a la chance à plaisir d'avoir
une mosaïque culturelle importante
puisqu'on a près de 40 ethnies
différentes qui cohabitent en toute
sérénité l'idée donc c'est évidemment de
permettre à chacun un petit peu de
valoriser sa culture ou de venir
découvrir la culture du voisin
[Musique]
direction Poissy à présent l'espace
jeunesse la source propose une journée
portes ouvertes Gabriel oui et une
journée à destination des jeunes picia
kays au programme information autour des
séjours d'été découverte des points
accueil et coûte jeunesse prévention et
divers ateliers alors il y aura du
street dance de l'afro dance ou encore
du chant et de la musique le but
présenter les différentes actions et
rencontrer les équipes de l'espace
jeunesse ce sera l'occasion aussi de
vous inscrire pour la rentrée 2023 2024
du sport à présent Gabriel avec un
événement à Rambouillet oui une journée
particulière pour les fans d'équitation
alors je sais pas si vous le savez
autour de la table mais le 11 juin c'est
le jour qu'a choisi la Fédération
française d'équitation pour la fête du
poney alors au programme découverte de
l'équitation tombola avec stage a gagné
ou encore démonstration et atelier
pédagogique sur le cheval et
l'équitation c'est de 14 heures à en
présence de la reine du muguet 2023 la
rambolitaine Jessica Gomez et de sa
dauphine oui j'ai déjà reçu un mail dans
ma boîte aux lettres Gabriel pour la
fête du poney non je pense pas que je
vais y aller mais j'ai envie de tout le
monde à y aller on termine avec un
concours d'éloquence Gabriel ce sera
dimanche soir à Mantes-la-Jolie oui
l'association Jeunesse sans frontière
présente ce dimanche la grande finale de
son concours d'éloquence les jurys
l'artiste Kery James l'avocat pénaliste
Ibrahim Chalabi ou encore la militante à
l'origine de la marche de la dignité
Amal bentounzi devant leurs yeux les
jeunes de Mantes-la-Jolie performeront
sur différents sujets l'aboutissement
d'un travail de plusieurs semaines
réaliser avec leur mentor parmi les
sujets la banlieue populaire est-elle
définie par la violence ou encore
peut-on échapper à son destin des thèmes
au cœur des engagements de l'association
qui lutte contre les clichés autour de
la banlieue alors depuis 2019 jeunesse
sans frontières accompagnent la jeunesse
menteuse grâce à différents dispositifs
théâtraux sportifs ou encore pédagogique
alors si vous voulez profiter du
spectacle et les soutenir rendez-vous à
18h30 au cinéma CGR de Mantes-la-Jolie
et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel Gontier
comme d'habitude petit tour de plateau
bah vous on va commencer par vous vous
sentez le concours d'éloquence est-ce
que d'être un beau spectacle à mon avis
je suis d'accord avec vous ATIS François
Jolivet est-ce que vous avez une
préférence
partagez également
allez on fait un saut à Guyancourt à
présent samedi dernier la commune
proposée une urban color avec des
animations et des démonstrations tout au
long de la journée le moment phare la
color run le reportage de Grégory
cannelle Mélanie poquet et Gabriel
Gonthier
non il n'y a pas eu de pluie coloré à
Guyancourt la commune 50 chinoise
organisait tout simplement sa toute
première color run au cœur du quartier
de Villaroy on a passé un bon moment
voilà c'est festif c'est coloré et puis
voilà on est là pour pour faire cette
course de bonne humeur bah je trouvais
que c'était un super projet avec toute
l'histoire des couleurs qu'on nous lance
twist a vraiment un moment assez fun
entre amis ou en famille
c'est super bien passé l'ambiance était
très bonne et puis bah on a été bien
bien décoré tous pas de souci
on a terminé comme ça
c'est bien franchement ça va faire en
famille c'est très bien à faire une
course
d'été de
7 pas de classement pas de chronomètre
juste 5 km à
parcours avant de découvrir de nombreux
sports et arurbain on avait initié une
première fête des sports Urbains on a
souhaité effectivement l'étoffer avec un
rendez-vous qui deviendra maintenant
annuel un fil conducteur qui est cette
color run 350 participants c'était
inscrit pour ce rendez-vous de quoi voir
la vie en couleur le temps d'une journée
avant d'aller se nettoyer la caméra elle
aussi y est passé
allez c'est l'heure à présent de passer
sur notre chronique sur le bien-être
animal
[Musique]
et donc c'est avec vous à Tiz barré ce
soir du coup on a été rejoint par Léo un
petit chat un petit chat un petit Léo un
petit chat de 2 ans donc aujourd'hui
j'ai mis ma blouse et puis je suis en
compagnie de notre petit Léo qui est là
je le remercie d'être devenu là sous les
lumières pour parler donc du vaccin la
vaccination qui est très importante pour
protéger donc nos amis les chats de
maladies qui peuvent être graves très
graves et même mortel alors quels sont
ces maladies Athis alors il y a
plusieurs maladies on va commencer
d'abord
donc par le coryza qui est une maladie
virale et contagieuse
oui
donc les signes cliniques donc ce sont
les éternuesments les écoulements au
niveau donc
écoulement nasaux au niveau
oculaire il y a également une fatigue
générale de l'animal si vous ne faites
pas vacciner une de la fièvre avec une
baisse de l'appétit c'est pas la maladie
la plus répandue au niveau des chats
notamment des Chats Sauvages oui oui
fait partie des maladies c'est pour ça
que je l'ai cité en premier ouais c'est
une maladie vraiment très virale donc
c'est très important de faire vacciner
son chat
renouveler tous les ans ou alors c'est
un vaccin oui des rappels à effectuer je
vais l'expliquer après par la suite j'ai
eu des rappels qui sont à faire et donc
il y a d'autres maladies dont c'est
important de faire vacciner son chat
vous avez aussi le typhus qui est une
maladie qui religieuse et ce virus en
fait il est très résistant dans
l'environnement et il peut être très
mortel pour les chatons parce qu'en fait
c'est une maladie qui va provoquer des
vomissements qui va vous provoquer la
diarrhée les chatons vont être très
affaiblis et ça va conduire
maladie mortelle vous avez également la
locomose la loco c'est une maladie
virale qui se transmet par la salive
donc les chats en partageant une même
gamelle d'eau vont se transmettre la
maladie par le sang quand ils vont se
bagarrer en période de chaleur et autres
la maladie peut se transmettre et même
si votre chat ne sort pas il peut se la
maladie peut se transmettre par le biais
de la maman à son enfant donc le chat il
peut être assez automatique ne présenter
aucun signe au départ et puis une fois
que les signes vont commencer à se
présenter ça va se renouveler sans cesse
alors justement à quelle fréquence
faut-il faire ses vaccins à 10 alors ces
vaccins là donc ils sont à effectuer
donc le premier vaccin est à faire à
partir de deux mois et demi et ensuite
c'est toutes les quatre semaines jusqu'à
au sixième mois de l'animal et après on
renouvelle on fait les rappels jusqu'au
1 an de l'animal c'est dans les
premières premiers mois justement qui
sont le plus susceptibles d'attraper ces
maladies à partir de alors deux mois et
demi pourquoi parce qu'en fait le chat
n'est plus à l'été par la maman donc il
n'est plus protégé par par l'allaitement
et donc après donc il faut renouveler et
il y a également une maladie qui est
très mortelle la rage donc la maladie
commune entre le chien et le chat cette
maladie se transmet à l'homme elle est
très mortelle elle va jouer sur les
troubles comportementaux et c'est un
vaccin qui est obligatoire quand vous
partez également à l'étranger on va vous
demander ce vaccin là et également sur
les lieux de vacances on vous demande
bien de présenter le vaccin contre la
rage et alors si jamais on n'est pas à
jour dans ces vaccins ATIS est-ce que
c'est grave est-ce que c'est dangereux
est-ce qu'on peut rattraper son retard
oui alors on ne s'inquiète pas on
s'inquiète un petit peu quand même
t'inquiète pas
on reprend les vaccins dès le départ
bien sûr on consulte tout le temps son
vétérinaire son vétérinaire c'est lui
qui va installer le protocole en
fonction de l'âge de l'animal de son
mode de vie comme on dit on habite chez
son chat c'est pas lui qui habite chez
nous mais c'est nous qui habitons chez
notre chat et alors même si on a un chat
d'intérieur qui ne sort jamais c'est
important quand même de faire ses
vaccins oui c'est très important les
gens ont souvent posent la question mon
chat ne sort pas mais vous vous pouvez
porter de maladie avec vos vêtements vos
chaussures vous allez faire du théâtre
vous allez mettre différents
déguisements vous avez côtoyé plein de
personnes vous allez plein de costumes
vous allez porter des maladies avec vous
bien merci beaucoup à tous barré pour
toutes ces précisions on vous retrouve
bientôt pour une prochaine chronique oui
très bientôt pour préparer l'été il fait
très chaud pour nos animaux et bien
merci beaucoup à tous c'est bientôt la
fin de cette émission mais juste avant
de se quitter je vous propose de jeter
un coup d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil sera toujours
parmi nous dans les Yvelines mais le
ciel sera légèrement envolé à
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Rambouillet au
niveau des températures il fera 22 à 21
degrés en moyenne dans l'après-midi même
programme du soleil avec un ciel
légèrement voilé côté température il
fera 29 degrés à Houdan Versailles et
Rambouillet et 30 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et pour les prévisions
météo de ce week-end vous avez
l'habitude maintenant c'est notre Mister
météo Thomas fléchir qui prend les
commandes à votre avis il s'est penché
sur quelle thématique sur quel sujet sur
quelle journée mondiale ce n'était pas
donné d'indice j'ai vu quelques quelques
extraits
voilà la question elle va en tout cas
sachez qu'aujourd'hui c'est la journée
mondiale du tricot alors du coup Thomas
Fisher s'est intéressé à cette activité
regardez
alors quoi de beau bonjour à tous alors
quoi de beau ce week-end dans les
Yvelines alors déjà il fait très beau un
peu chaud là je le ressens j'espère que
le micro il est waterproof alors
normalement les chaleurs vont se
poursuivre tout le week-end mais en tout
cas sachez que samedi c'est la journée
internationale du tricot donc là il fait
vraiment chaud le tricot ça réchauffe je
sais pas pourquoi ils ont mis ça à cette
date là donc on va tricoter pour ce beau
samedi donc je vais rejoindre Brigitte
je gère moi pour être tricoté tout ça
donc bonjour Brigitte vous faites du
tricot oui depuis plus de 40 ans ok un
peu d'expérience quoi un peu
d'expérience et alors moi j'ai jamais
commencé j'ai jamais testé est-ce que là
par exemple je peux apprendre tout de
suite et devenir le roi du tricot là ça
va peut-être un peu un peu compliqué
mais on peut regarder les bases alors
les aiguilles dépendent de la taille du
fil le feu il est gros plus le numéro
d'aiguille est gros ok donc là c'est du
2 et demi quoi
c'est c'est les torsades alors là faut
déjà un peu plus d'expérience pour qu'on
va se faire quelques torsades
on teste
avec l'index mais dans le pouce
voilà
OK et
avec
alors
elle a déjà le Move et beaucoup plus
simple en dessous il faut tendre avec
mais j'arrive pas à attendre sur les
deux
et là ça se voit que ça va vraiment vite
[Musique]
oui
pardon
sur ton aiguille là
j'ai pas le hop encore et comment tu as
appris ça toi Brigitte difficilement
parce que je te dis je suis gaucher donc
tout est droit pour les droitiers avec
une de mes tentes ok et tu es gauchère
il y a pas des ciseaux
je prends du coup celle-là là
j'ai arrêté de serrer j'ai arrêté de
tenir j'ai l'impression que l'histoire
du coup c'est une connerie et là maman
qui me manque vraiment
et que je vais mettre dans lequel dans
ce cadre de ma droite là
je l'avais presque
je transpire Brigitte là oh là là
et je sens que je suis pas loin mais je
vois pas comment je passe d'un fil d'un
fil en fil je l'ai perdu j'ai tout perdu
là
bam j'ai l'impression que c'était moi
qui font plus que les mêmes quand même
là ah mais à la vache en fait j'ai
compris je crois le principe
je crois que j'ai fait ma boucle je l'ai
mis
en même temps
pour aller plus vite je fais deux par
deux mois
allez le petit cul
le tricot pas si simple apparemment pour
Thomas Fletcher et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
et un excellent weekend prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]